well welcome um sorry for the delay
um but bit unfortunate so
on tonight's agenda uh we'll call
firstly for
apologies i have apologies from murray
and
joan are there any other apologies
we haven't got duncan so i'm not sure if
he can actually connect to us
so i can't see anyone case i'll be
relying on you
so all right and we'll add duncan to
that list
so um someone prepared to move
i'll move we accept them because they're
a second are there
happy the second jim kirsten thank you
you've come up thanks kirsten
all those in favor please say aye to the
kind
clear carried now we have two items
um not on the agenda and understanding
order
912 matters on not on the agenda
after item 15 will briefly go
into committee uh and that's to
receive the public excluded minutes that
you have had
uh circulated we need to do the reason
it's not on the agenda was the matter
was overlooked
and we it needs to be dealt with now to
protect the public
excluded information so that's one item
that we'll deal with
after item 15 and a wee bit
later just straight after item nine and
before members
okay you don't know about this either
i'm sorry four members
information the issue of flexton road
came up tonight and i had in a
quick a bit of an emergency meeting with
don young
paul was there his writing portfolio
and the mayor and dawn's going to brief
us
very very briefly on that
and then it'll come back to the next
board meeting and we have to do that
tonight
as well so i'll deal with that i after
item
nine so right moving on
just so you're aware look please just
call out if you
want to ask me anything or a point
because i i can see k
all the time so she can bring me up
today confirmation
minutes are there any corrections to the
minutes
appear to be none so someone prepared to
move the adoption
of the minutes i'm low that jim thanks
paul
seconded by morris morris thanks morris
i'll put that all those in favor please
say i i
declare it carried are there any matters
arising
there appear to be none so we've got a
deputation uh or a presentation now from
grant mcleod this is just to bring the
board
a quick update on the milton reserve you
remember that was a
issue that came up when we were talking
about our budgets
uh last meeting so grant
welcome and over to you well thanks jim
uh hi everybody for those who don't know
me i'm grant mccloud i'm the green space
uh manager here at wyoming through
district council um
now i'm just going to do some screen
sharing uh
just because i have a presentation here
so
um hopefully that's coming up for uh for
everybody now
um so look just in line with that as
well i understand at the last meeting
and apologies that i couldn't be there i
was um
at the peak assess residence meeting at
the same time
um that there was also some uh queries
around some of the tan entrances as well
and i thought i'd just briefly run
through those although i do have flex
and i'm here and given that don's going
to go into that in some detail later on
i might just kind of breeze through that
one and get through to
get through to milton as well if there's
any questions
at all throughout the presentation
obviously just um alert me grab my
attention i've got the gallery of you on
so i can
see most of you um otherwise
yes here we go
so look this just wanted to go through
the town entrances one of the first
things
uh just to raise is obviously there has
been a strategy that's been put together
um myself and joanne have both been
aware of that it's been through the
business centres team
they've also attributed some budget to
that as well so
what we're looking for there is just
some consistency around the
levels of service that we're actually
going to be putting into place with
with those town entrances now the main
ones that i think the board were
interested to kind of hear about was
obviously
uh kippenberg is one of the um important
ones that's had quite a lot of
discussion
in recent times myself dan
and jim last year had some meetings with
um
with main power now they uh
sort of came to a little bit of an end
and that's really because of the fact
that we're now starting to see
um some discussion around whether or not
the undergrounding which was
originally said no to um
may now actually come to be so one of
the issues there for board members that
aren't aware
is that we have power lines directly
above some trees that we've got there
and
um at the minute main power basically
going through every two years to
cut the trees back that's obviously
splaying them in a way that we're not
overly enthralled with because it has to
happen
because of the the infrastructure that's
here but it is compromising the trees
and unfortunately
uh topping them all the time like that
is kind of creating a little bit of a
stunted growth for them
so we were looking at a different kind
of planting that we could do there and
main power were quite keen to put some
money into that at the time
since that moment though there has been
some discussion around whether or not
the development that would happen right
and behind it would actually come
forward and be done a lot sooner
so that's kind of put that whole project
into question now because if we go
through and do
do the development that would in essence
become an urban roading corridor
which would have a whole new entrance
into quite a substantial subdivision
um so it's sort of we've got a design
there however it will end up
being inappropriate if that does occur
so yes um
line side road so just moving on to
there obviously we've got some works
that are currently going on as well that
pdu
and the roading team are doing on behalf
of the council
part of that is putting in some new
footpaths and also
working with the board around the the
tree planting that we might get to put
in there as well
that works currently underway so you'll
note that whenever you
go down there or drive down there
actually there's quite a lot of work
that's going on and
that project is kind of marching on
really well so i think that that's due
for completion sometime soon if i'm
if i'm not incorrect joe or don
now the board has contributed quite a
lot of money into that area for planting
and you'll recall last year that we had
a bit of an issue with the mpd
and then removing some of the the old
oak trees that we had there so we've
managed to retain
one the it's an interesting drumbeat
um the idea being that we'll go and
we'll put some further trees down
through that area as well to try and
carry on that corridor
um so there's still some further work to
do there there's also been a slight
complication and i'm
meeting with a chat from auckland
tomorrow over the phone um
to talk about the fact that there's an
led billboard which
is being consented on the morrison's car
site
um so i need to talk to them because
obviously they've now got some concerns
around where we would put the trees but
at the same time
we want to create the avenue effect so
we have to come to a bit of a discussion
there to see if there's a middle ground
that we can find otherwise that may be
one that i'm
bringing back to the board to have a bit
of a chat about
at some stage so that's just to give you
a heads up there
um and as i said flexton wrote as well
but i'll not dwell on this one too long
given that um
don's going to be talking about this
specifically later on um
sorry paul you go there i picked the
lionfi road
oh that's very cool it just yeah
road was nelson petroleum going to
pay for a couple of extra trees on that
side
so they planted three trees um we
tried to push with them that they might
want to give a donation to the
council in terms of the trees that were
going to be removed but they dug their
heels in
their basic uh feedback was that unless
you remove that big oak tree we're not
willing to give you anything
oh yeah um we're not willing to move
that big oak tree so
we kind of came to a bit of an impasse
um
yeah that's that's basically where that
ended up yeah thank you
[Music]
um so yep so flexton road um so there's
obviously an opportunity there that we
might have a secondary um
option through townsend fields um in
terms of actually creating a bit of an
avenue effect
into into the area of iron entrance
there may also be some room potentially
for landscaping but the reality is it's
going to be pretty limited so we're
working with three waters there
um who are also working with the keep
ringing or a beautiful group um that are
looking at some planting around the
soils the stormwater areas that we've
got down there
so that's that's an ongoing piece of
work
so melton memorial reserve project um
so currently we've got budget and the
annual plan and also into the ltp for
the finalization of the concept plan
which was
um uh
consulted on back in 2015 and
a plan actually developed now a major
part of that was
what you see now is the current dog park
plus also the croquet greens that have
gone in there and also setting out an
area where the dock office is currently
situated
that plan had been consulted on quite
widely with the public there was a few
things that they said used to and no too
obviously there was a playground touted
for the area but given the dog park's
location and that was decided to be an
inappropriate mix of activities
as you can imagine a whole bunch of kids
running around a playground next to a
dog park
probably going to hype them up so not
quite the right mix of
activities there one of the things that
did come back through that was the fact
that milton really
would be a good spot for a i think the
term that they used in the previous
report was a memorable entrance to
ring aura now with the cold stream
development with the stadium this is
obviously going to become a more
significant
entrance into the area with more people
traveling through there
so that's some of the current thinking
that we've got we've
got a current development plan um that
includes an extension to the dog park
with a dog agility area
and it's also highlighting the fact that
we'd be doing a native planting area as
well
now you would have heard from trevor
wright at the last board meeting who did
a deputation and one of his ideas is
that he's quite keen for an arboretum or
some kind of special
tree planting for the area that's just
they're just a couple of the things that
we've kind of got going on here there's
also the potential for the model railway
club who are currently situated on black
street
um have highlighted the fact that they'd
be quite keen on
milton park as well now
so they're in the there in the mix as
well so where we're kind of at is that
we've got
an existing concept plan which allows
for an extension to the dog park with
the dog agility area we've got quite an
expectant
group there with the friends of dog park
who you know they're well aware of that
and um you know they see the
the money and the budgets to to assist
with some work down there
they're also fundraising at this point
in time as well for their own agility
equipment so that they'd actually be
paying into that
into that project with that one um plus
we've got some other groups that are
coming in who have quite a high interest
in this and
for the um keep ringing or beautiful and
also so for some work that the board
have done in previous years we've had
some tree planting down through there as
well to help create that avenue effect
so you can see there that we've got
quite a bit of planning to do this year
the reality is if we stray away from the
current development plan that we've got
we are going to have to go out and
re-engage with it now
that plan's at least five years old um
so there is some there is some sense in
opening up that conversation we know
that we've got some very interested
groups there and we know that there's
a lot of the public who may not recall
the plan that was
developed previously and perhaps it
doesn't quite go as far as they'd want
it to
so really what i wanted to do was kind
of bring the board up to speed with what
was happening here
there was also an opportunity or a
discussion around whether or not the
board would want to put some of the
landscaping fund into this project
there'd certainly be opportunity for
that given the level of area that we've
got and the amount of planting that you
could achieve within there
and if we were to look at a not
necessarily a garden but some kind of
arboretum or
tree specimen planting area then we
would
it could definitely utilize the funds
for that
so that's in a nutshell kind of where
we're at with the project
um if i have time jim i'm very happy to
just thank thanks very much for the
grant i think
what the board probably would need is an
update
workshop with you uh so that everyone's
well aware of what the plans were five
years ago i'm
i can't totally recollect what the ideas
were
i wasn't aware for example that you had
a lot of money put aside
until recently for future years we need
a workshop
i think with you to get some idea of
that without making any commitments of
course
and to get an idea what your thoughts
are there what the board's thoughts are
on the development on the dog park and
uh those
other issues and what
what changes would be made or could be
made
if the board puts some not saying all of
it some or
a bit of it or all of it some money
towards it would that help
bring the planning forward or what so i
don't know what other board members
think but i think that we probably need
a workshop
uh hopefully when we can get together
because it's pretty difficult
on this form so what what's your
thoughts
there
just can i say that there is some
urgency for the dog park because
the group was already currently in
fundraising mode they've got a
a concept plan that they want to consult
on so they're a long way down the track
compared to some of these other groups
and they've just been waiting to see if
the council will provide the fencing
um how soon can we get an answer back to
them because
it's actually holding up their
fundraising well that's interesting
kirsten because the board hasn't had any
briefings or approach from the dog park
people as to whether the board would
support
them to extend we spent over a hundred
thousand on that dog park so far i mean
i mean i i don't i don't know i'm sorry
jim i was asking that of grant
sorry how soon we could get a briefing
back uh yeah well we can come to the
next board meeting or if there's
um some urgency around this i could work
with kay for a
specific date for a a workshop on that
the thing what the board members think
do you want a special meeting workshop
meeting or would the september meeting
be
all right do you want to do it
well i didn't know there was any urgency
on it either i'm quite happy for a
briefing but i wasn't aware of any
urgency on it jim
yeah same position as i've got robbie
sorry
the funding was promised to the dog park
in 2019 so
it's been delayed with covert i'm afraid
well i i i'm going to just interrupt the
wee bit because i thought the board had
a say in that
nothing has come to the board on that
the board the previous board
uh supported the hundred thousand was
spent there and they
mostly thought that was sufficient i
have to have to save the dog park in the
interim so
i'm sorry jim i could show you the
correspondence from david ears
i i i'm aware that you haven't i'm not
talking about the council i'm talking
about the community board
yeah yeah i'm a councillor and i
actually haven't um
seen any correspondence and all that
grammar about the um
the alterations or any plans as well so
i'd be quite um
keen for grant to bring something to the
community board
in the council so we so i at least know
what's going
on exactly because they're talking about
matching
council contribution with double what
the money so therefore
we need to consider all that when we
look at it absolutely
are you talking about we being council
or community board kirsten
both yeah is the board happy to have a
briefing at the next meeting or do you
want it sooner
[Music]
anyone if there's no urgency i think
at the board meeting would be perfectly
fine if there isn't an urgency i'm
hearing from someone there could be
but if the majority thinks that there
isn't then maybe we should just wait
till september
the next ball meeting would be fine all
i'm saying is please don't leave it
another six months
yeah fair enough yep no no we we need to
move it on that was
that's the intent of the briefing
tonight so if
everyone's happy with that um
are you happy with that grant to come
back to the next meeting
i'm sorry jim but i thought tonight was
going to be the night we saw the plan
for the milton memorial reserve so
yeah i'm a bit surprised we've seen so
little tonight
i don't know where you got that idea
from that was never
that was never part of the workshop it
was it was on
on the agenda was the milton reserve
update it wasn't
talking about the final plans or
anything it was to bring this up to date
as a result of the last board
meeting where i think we were all
surprised to learn that the
council had been budgeting ahead on this
and the board knew nothing so
that was the basis of grant coming
tonight right
yeah well while grant's here i actually
went for a walk around there the other
day right around
the other side of melton reserve i don't
know if grant's aware there's a
heck of a lot of rubbish and bottles and
um card tyres and a lot of stuff been
lying there for
a long period of time right past
um department of conservation right to
the um
the giveaway sign or stop sign and then
you cross the road
onto the um you know royal air park
um trees and whatever you are and you
walk down that walkway there
both sides of the walkway there's quite
a lot of rubbish lying around so
i don't know um who's meant to clean
that all up
um yeah that's that's a surprise because
that should that shouldn't be happening
so is that on all three
boundaries there paul or is it just one
in particular uh all three boundaries
actually
and then when you cross the road against
the fence on the dog park side
there's a whole lot of um beer bottles
and what have you there as well
so quite a bit of rubbish around there
yep with respect paul that should just
go in as a service request so you should
just put that through
as a service request i realize that okay
thanks for raising there paul and grant
scott
is there any other questions of grant
all right grant well thanks thanks very
much for coming along and that
briefing is on that and we'll see you at
the next board meeting so
okay that'll be good so thanks thank you
very much thank you
right item five there's no adjourned
business
item six on pages 19 to 35
is the south brook road pedestrian
improvements uh
jig are you there for that
don yes um i'm here jim
and it'll be a bit of a tag team between
jig and myself
so with me just starting the ball
rolling the board
will recall that we've had a project
on the books to look at the south brook
road improvements
and we began that process looking very
broadly at the major improvements we
could make
and you've received a briefing
previously from a consultant that the
council hired that looked at
a whole range of option well not so much
options but issues
uh and appropriate use of the space in
terms of trying to deal with those
i think it became clear to everybody at
that time that there
are a large number of issues that really
need to be worked through there
and at a recent meeting the board agreed
that it would postpone that large-scale
review of south brook road until some of
the
wider issues had fallen into place and
would concentrate instead
on a much more achievable goal of
improving improving pedestrian crossings
of south brook
following on from that we've asked our
internal consultants pdu
to look at what our options are and the
result of that is jig has prepared
a report which is in front of you
today and you'll see the recommendations
in the covering report
uh where we are seeking your
mandate to consult with the community
uh on those uh our preferred option in
principle
uh subject to that consultation um
and if i could just throw over to jig
now to to briefly
uh talk through that report and then
we'll be open for any questions
thanks don gig hi everyone my name is
jake
um i work in the pdu team i'm a design
engineer and i'm looking into south
brook road
um so in the report that i've done we've
basically had a look at a few design
options for southwark road and what we
can do to improve some of the
safety in particular we had a look at
pedestrian safety
but we've also considered some of the
other elements such as
some of the congestion as well as
cyclists um
because we've got we've got all those
users in the area
so for those that don't know um
southwark road
is one of the busiest roads um in
renewal we've got about 26 000 vehicles
that are
driving through there every day um with
our peak time being about 11 o'clock
on a saturday morning um so we'll
we had a look at a few options into
improving the pedestrian safety um
there's a large number of pedestrians
that are crossing south brook road
particularly to get to the two schools
that are in the area as well as that
kindergarten that's near dench's road
and marshall road
when we had a look at the locations we
were thinking about the different
groups of pedestrians that would be
crossing south brook road
um and we came across there's four main
groups
there's the ones that are coming in from
the north that are coming in from north
of
um southbound area to cross the road
the way we see it those those
pedestrians can cross at those south
brook south belt intersection
traffic lights the second group would be
those coming in from the south
say from coronation street area
um the third group would be from the
pearsons
near near about pearson's lane and all
those houses in between
and they're crossing south brook road
generally these pedestrians are crossing
from the existing pedestrian crossing
and then the last group are those that
are driving in from the south
dropping their kids off on south brook
road and then crossing the road
so when we considered these three
catchments we considered okay so how big
are each of these groups um
and we we justified it based on the
amount of people that are coming in from
these
groups and how what infrastructure that
they have originally so
we're at the large the largest group of
pedestrians that we've got is on that
south brook south front
north northern node however they've
already got their infrastructure there
so we
rank them a little bit less
so we looked at potential options for
putting traffic
traffic signals for these pedestrians
across the road and the way we saw it
there are three locations that we could
put traffic signals somewhere near
dench's road
in the southbound intersection we could
signalize the existing pedestrian
crossing
or we could signalize the tully street
coronation street intersection
with the torley street coronation street
intersection we saw that there was a
potential to
combine the project with another project
that nzta is offering funding for called
the innovative street
project um bill was looking into some
options and
considering turning the the school roads
which is denches road and marshall road
one way so we had a look at potentially
considering the one-way option for
option number three
um we undertook a multi-criteria
analysis
multi-criteria assessment with a group
of roading engineers
as well as me and don we had a look at
the different categories which were
pedestrian cyclists and vehicles and
our best ranked options the highest rate
option
was signalizing that tallest street
intersection
with one way we saw multiple benefits
in that aspect which include
efficiency of the southbrook road
efficiency of the wider network so which
includes dentures and marshall street
safety impacts for all the pedestrians
so the pedestrians are able to cross the
road and they're not having to walk
a long distance to cross the road as
well as cyclists are able to use
the pedestrian the signalized
intersection and safely turn
um going from there we we also had a
look at some of the other options
we looked at while tourist street was
our favorite option
and um our highest rank option we
considered our second highest ranked
option which was
signalizing the existing pedestrian
crossing the main reason why we didn't
really like the signalizing the existing
pedestrian crossing is it didn't have
much
benefit to the um to the road network
it wouldn't help with the congestion and
there was a chance that if we
look into two lane for landing that road
in the future
then there's a chance we might have to
rip that out so
it wasn't it wasn't our preferred and
our least preferred option was that
dentures road intersection
the way we see it we we didn't want more
traffic to go
past the school and use the traffic
lights to turn
because um we would see a lot more rat
runners down
down through the school that way so
those the first adventures road option
was
we we didn't consider at all but we did
consider the existing pedestrian
crossing
and the tourist street signalizing the
tully street
going further from that we considered
two design options
two ways that those two options would
look
would look like on paper and we've drawn
them up
so the first drawing in our in my report
um
i'm not sure if everyone has my report
in front of them but um
i've labeled that option three layer two
option three layout two so basically
this this would see the um
two lanes going northbound so we would
have two lanes going northbound all the
way from pack and save through to torley
street
the way we see it that would improve
would have two lanes that would improve
some road um
efficiency that way so we wouldn't have
people working and then merging out and
then merging and
merging out so um let's see some
improvement there
however because our road is constricted
this has meant two things
one we've only got one lane going
southbound and two we've got a shared
footpath and cycle way
secondly with this option we've had a
look at the option of
being able to do the one-way system
through the the school
streets this would see a right turn bay
turning down dench's road
the second option that we've considered
criminalizing the tully street denture
um strength section is
um we've still got that two way
northbound
and one way southbound however we
haven't we've removed
the right turn into tallest street
basically that gives us some space to
keep the pedestrians and cyclists
separate
which means safer for them however
for those people that want to turn right
they would have to turn right down
dench's road
and go go through that one-way system
this would see improvements in terms of
the school traffic where the school
traffic would be able to turn right down
dentures drop their kids off
turn down to left straight and come out
the um come out the
signalized traffic lights to turn right
i'm not sure if everyone anyone's been
there during school time it's very
difficult to
to turn out
the second design option that we
considered was signalizing the existing
pedestrian crossing
we saw two options for this uh for this
one option would say
just we would just put some traffic
lights in the islands in the stay away
that they are
so a kid would push the button on one
side go to the get to the middle of the
road and then push another button and go
to the other side of the road
option number three oh sorry option
number two for
signalizing the existing pedestrian
crossing is that would just have one
signalized crossing so a kid would cross
a
would press a button and cross the whole
road while cars waited on both sides
and the way the way we saw it um c-top
were in preference of option number one
where they pushed the button get to the
middle and then go again
the c-top being our canterbury traffic
operations centre
that we consulted with during this
design process
and in terms of budget we also spoke
their talk
for about the budget and spoke to them
about our budget for this project which
was
425 000 um they were saying that
generally these sort of signalizing
traffic light intersections really
depend on
um a number of criteria mostly how much
traffic is going through the road and
what sort of traffic management
requirements that we need
they estimated that signalizing existing
pedestrian crossing would cost somewhere
between
three hundred thousand to five hundred
thousand
um however they said that our preferred
option which was
signalizing the torley street
intersection
would cross somewhere between 2.2
million
roughly which is similar to what we
spent on
the south brook southbound intersection
so with all said and done um
we would like to take all these options
out to the community to see what they
think
we've made a few meetings with the
schools to talk through these options
after this
board meeting so um hopefully we'll
we'll see how that goes hopefully
they're happy with our options
okay thanks thanks jig any questions of
don and jig
no questions all right someone prepared
to
move move if i can get in i can't sorry
it's robbie here
um just with regard the
obvious question is going to be is there
going to be some sort of
um cohesion between the traffic lights
that are currently there
and a possible new set of traffic lights
so that people aren't stop start stop
start
which happens frequently in the city
yes so um some of the newer lights in
the city they've
got this new system where i'm not sure
if you've been there you can just drive
straight through so
um with our systems they're all
compatible with that so we can make them
go
um so when one turns green then you'll
be a green on the next one green on the
next one
and the cl the clearway option
is the clearway options not uh in here
is the clearway option still on the
table
as part of this uh consultation
the wider treatment of
the full stretch uh robbie will is
is i suppose in a way being parked up
uh for the meantime and all all this
work will do
is is look at crossing the road uh
getting
pedestrians across the road and so
any other option of what we do with
cyclists with pedestrians with vehicles
with buses
will will not be addressed as as part of
this work what we will be looking to
ensure is that we do future proof our
design
so that it will allow for whatever of
those options may emerge in the future
um and we will have the space to do so
just answering your first question as
well a little further to uh jiggs answer
what we're anticipating is that during
peak morning
and peak evening the trigger for
the lights would be set on a timer
and so on that basis we would be able to
you know green wave the uh the light so
that they
went one after the other and that would
also ensure that
uh the traffic didn't stop because one
child came along and and pushed the
button
um they would be you know waiting for
their three or four or five minutes
whatever the timing would be
until such time as the timer had
switched and
and they went across and that would
allow us to batch
the pedestrians together in the off peak
time
uh we would probably then just convert
it back to a sensor
type arrangement where either a car
coming out coronation street
or a or a pedestrian pushing the button
would stop the traffic so that they
could cross
jim kirsten here further questions
sorry um don can you confirm do
do we have an indication of whether we
can get any funding
for that potential 1.5 to 3 million
cost for the preferred option from nzta
we have an indication kirsten but not a
guarantee and it's come in two different
meetings with them the first meeting we
had
was when we were alluding to them what
we were thinking of
and the first person who was speaking i
guess
um placed a bit of uh
cold water on our thoughts
but the second person uh was in the
meantime
uh thinking about and and and looking
into the
um the current status and pointed out
that that kia crossing
is so far out of um
the guidelines uh that it in fact
probably quite significantly swayed
the ability to get funding quite a bit
back the other way
since that time joanne met just today
with the with the right person again
with the funding
and they are certainly obviously as
you're well aware we now
begin a new three-year cycle of funding
um so whatever we spend this year must
be spent and and there's no guarantee of
anything after june
um but this the signals very much are
that they believe that
an application for this would be viewed
very sympathetically
uh it coming in the new three year round
now whether that appeared in the first
year we couldn't guarantee that but it's
certainly
um they are positive uh
of the uh the benefit of this work
so following up to from that question
are you comfortable going to the
community with these options
when there's a possibility that this one
won't be funded
i think we are definitely and it's a
very good point we'll definitely be
making sure that the caveats are well
clear uh that this this is um you know
at this stage not guaranteed but we will
be
uh claiming the money um
but there is no guarantee as to either
whether it will be
funded or if so the timing of that so um
yes we're sort of well aware that we
need to wrap that caveat around and it
is a slightly
tricky conversation to have um but
of course we can't wait uh for that
confirmation
if we're going to spend our money this
year or on the on the design and get it
ready to go
and and just a question from the traffic
engineering following up from robbie's
question
um what is the traffic modeling save for
the afternoon
uh when the traffic lights are
signalized for the school children to
cross and the traffic is backed up
past might attend and pack and save is
that going to block that intersection
to be honest we haven't yet got into the
detailed modelling stage of it
uh kirsten and that would come as part
of our next
phase and a lot of that will start to
determine things like
uh like the timing um
that that a particular phase will stay
uh
green before it triggers so there is
certainly quite a bit of work and i
think both you and robbie are right that
these
questions will be uppermost in people's
minds when we go to them
because as we all know the devil is in
the detail
but we don't have the answers to those
matters at this stage but they will be
well thought through before
we committed to a detailed design but
shouldn't you have those answers before
you go out for consultation
because it may not make it the preferred
option
it's a good challenge it's a good
challenge to put to us um
we are on a pretty tight time
frame as you can see from the from the
report in front of us
um and i guess if the board
is of a mind uh you know we could do
more work before we went
to the public but there is then an
increased
likelihood that we wouldn't proceed as
far as we
had hoped
any further questions of don
or jake all right uh it's someone we've
got a recommendation in front of us as
anyone i liked him over here move it i'd
move that moved by
paul not moved by paul have we a second
or second taken by robbie paul would you
wish to speak
no thank you you know i've looked into
it quite hard when i was on that wee bit
of a committee that we sort of studied
it quite hard and
had a couple meetings on it and i think
that is the um
the best proposal we can do for the
safety and everything for the street and
for long term
and i also think it will actually help
alleviate um a lot of the traffic
as well um going there so it it actually
hits the pedestrians really good
um i shouldn't play hits it's going to
help the pedestrians pretty good
also i personally believe it's going to
help a lot of the traffic
issues with the one-way of the people
dropping um
people off and they won't have to um
pull out against the
traffic and um it will also help cycling
side of it as well
so i think it's a win-win in all
directions so i'm
very supportive of doing what we're
looking at
okay robbie
robbie yeah look i agree with those
comments however
um with with regard to the win-win
there's still a heck of a lot of work to
to be done on this section of road hence
my question with regard to
clearways fully accept the comments that
don made
that it is going to be a work in
progress but i think
going out for consultation on this is a
good step in the
in the right direction uh fully
appreciating the questions that
kirsten asked um but i do think we need
to go out for
for consultation and if the public asks
those questions then we deal with those
questions
jim all right thank you robbie anyone el
anyone else wish to speak
yes kirsten kirsten
um i'm not going to impose obviously
going out to consultation i'm always
happy
to have conversations with our
ratepayers however i think this is
highly premature
i think that modelling work needs to be
done and and i actually am very very
concerned about this design i think that
the concept is absolutely brilliant
and for pedestrians but it is going to
clog up traffic in south brook
even worse than what we've got now from
what i've seen and it's
even going to cause some impacts on the
pack and save mitre 10
intersections so i'm hoping that'll come
out in the consultation
and that some more work will be done but
i'm really nervous about raising
people's expectations
when we do not have promise of funding
and we simply do not have 1.5 to 3
million dollars in the current budget
nzta's priorities have changed so we
may be hopeful of receiving a bit more
money but i would rather see this work
done properly
and i'm really nervous and that we're
going to get pushed back and that all
we're going to get is a signalized
crossing across
south brook road and that's literally
all we can afford with 425
000 so i just caution the idea of
raising too high in expectation
this does not solve the traffic issues
in south brook road it will make them
worse
but it will help the pedestrian in
cycling issues
any anybody else
uh paul do you want to reply no thank
you
all right i'll put the recommendation
you're aware of it all those in favor
please say hi
like to the country was there anyone
opposed i can't
see okay declare it carry
that takes us on to item 6.2
pages 36 to 40
request for parking restrictions joanna
are you
are you there hi jim yes i am
okay is joey in there yes okay
i haven't got you thank you
so this this report is asking the
community board to consider
a request for p120 parking on durham
street outside of durham health in the
pharmacy
um staff have been approached by durham
health requesting this time restriction
due to all day parking occurring outside
of the doctors in the pharmacy
and this affecting the patient access to
these services
there's two options which i have put in
the paper in front of the board for
consideration today
the first is to support the change of
four parks directly outside of durham
health and pharmacy
to change to p120 parking restrictions
well the second option is to decline the
request and continue to monitor the
parking within that area
i'm happy to take any questions uh you
may have on this
this report
right any questions of joanne one for me
yeah yeah joanne um go and help
durham um health how many
existing of their own car parking sites
have they got on site
um they do have a number of parks i
think they have around half a dozen at
the front and they also do have some
parks at the
at the rear and the pharmacy does have
some parking outside of it as well
i think this is about parking turnover
for them they obviously have
a number of people coming in
requiring access for a doctor's
appointments and also
picking up uh prescriptions and and the
like from the chemist
and and supplementary to that do you
know if they
um make their staff park in their own
car parks or do the staff park
um out on the road i believe the
staff will be parking on the road not in
the not in the doctor's car parks
okay further questions that you're in
there are none uh all right we've got a
recommendation in front of us
6.2 someone prepared to move move it
or move a recommendation
i can't see you all so uh just call out
i'll move jump someone forbid sorry is
that robbie
yeah robbie seconded by
i'll second them
symptomatic of uh uh increasing
industrialization albeit doctors and
pharmacies and what have you in our cbd
and i think it's uh this is necessary
thank you okay can i just confirm
[Music]
no i i agree with you robbie yeah and i
agree with robbie so it's something we
have to do really
any other member wish to
all right i'll put the recommendation
all those in favor please say aye
to the country clear it carried uh
i've just come up on my screen as
members know i'm struggling here
we but i see the mayor there welcome to
our meeting mr mayor nice to see you
there
right item 6.3 uh
bus bus stops kathy is she there
um okay
can you hear me okay you've got a bit of
an
echo there i can
there's a bit of a noise behind you
right yeah sorry i've got quite low
uh internet here so i don't have a
um a friend with call-in which would
have been helpful
okay you don't have one at all do you no
i'm afraid not
you're breaking up kathy
you can't hear you can't see oh she's
disappeared
i'm afraid she's are you there kathy
you're just coming back she's just
reconnecting um
right
no you're breaking up
i'm just gonna keep
i'm just going to hide my video because
that doesn't help also
i'll just um if it's okay
so sorry jim can you hear me now
i can can other members all here
yes right quickly um there are a number
of bus stops that have been
um looked at to uh service the new
uh bus routes the one being the rangiora
to pegasus route
and the uh blue line that is going to be
extending out west
of rangiora consultation has been done
with
a number of residents who are adjacent
to or affected by the bus stops
and where there has been any strong
objections
uh alternative locations have been
sought uh
there are just two stops and i'm not
gonna go through them all because
there's around 22 in the list
um but there are two stops that will
require
some removal of marked cast
car parking places um and the first one
of those
is a stop outside 406
a hyde street which is just west of the
cloud hotel
the resident there was while not overly
happy to have a
bus stop outside uh but accept that it
had to go somewhere but wanted to retain
some parking
his gateway and his property is there
although his
driveway is around the corner on a side
street
um the plow hotel uh we're happy
to lose some parking but suggested
the place uh putting it outside
there probably wasn't suitable so
um there's four spots four car park
spots that are just
west of the power's driveway on the
western side
which we could um remove the marked car
park there
and put the bus stop there um there's no
time restricted parking there it was
just
it's just that there are marked spots
the second one of note is uh down on
kippenberger ave
where there's an old existing bus
shelter
it was a shelter it was a stop uh before
uh there has been some car parked mark
there they would
have to be removed um and there's three
three there the residents there have
been um the owner of the property has
been spoken to and is happy for that
to be done um
just one other point is to we would like
to give
some consideration to a stock being
installed at some stage on blackett
street
which would provide greater coverage for
the rangiora to pegasus route
that would require removal of some time
restricted parking
in that area and consultation with a
couple of resident
uh residential and business properties
there
so i just i'm happy to take any
questions but as i say i won't go
through all the stops but
um there's a rather a long list there
are 22 stocks some that are
new some that are reinstated ones that
have been bus stops
that were used before and may have been
used by school buses of late
um and as mentioned just those two that
need to have the
car parking removed
thanks cathy is there any questions of
kathy if you've got concerns on any of
them
it's a good idea to ask kathy yes
one for me
yeah um kathy um
have we done a survey to see those ones
on high street
um how well those car parks are used are
they um
actually plenty of normal parking in
that area before we take them out
and also the same with chippenberg
avenue
so the ones in hyde street do get used
probably
um and this is just an observation uh of
my own
they they do get used uh when people are
stopping for the dairy
probably more often in the evening time
um
i have come through there several times
and there's been one or two cars parked
there is a number of car parking spaces
there
available we would still be retaining
three spots there and there's also all
the parking in front of the plow hotel
as well as the parking on the other side
the
hotel itself has a parking area as you
know and he was happy that
um parking out in the street wasn't uh
could be
uh removed to allocate for the bus
um kevin burger ave again uh
was some feedback from um one
business uh office staff who felt they
would have to walk further because
um well they thought they might have to
park further down the road they
certainly
uh think of parking and kippenberger
they're down but it would require people
to perhaps walk a little bit
um and the
uh daycare center which
is opposite the one i've mentioned with
car parking they
um acknowledged that the bus stop uh
could go there but they were also keen
to retain a
one or two part outside their place so
some of these we will have to monitor
and see if uh
parking people parking around the stock
on it yeah what i was mainly meaning was
the high street one particularly
um if you take um as the parking
uh completely full up there already you
know quite often or
um i know there's a bit of parking in
there
but because that parking completely full
now
well those four losing those four packs
um
adversely affect parking for um
the dairies and what have you for
example
so without uh sort of being there every
night and questioning or watching where
the people are going it's hard to
tell if that the car that might be
parked there or the one or two that they
may actually be in the pub
um and i guess we would have to do that
over a week to see whether
um people are just parking there because
it's easy or
uh parking there because they're going
to the dairy or crossing the road
certainly there is there's a side street
by the dairy there is a number of
parking
you know just roadside parking that is
available
um we tend to like having the bus stop
near a dairy as well because it's a safe
place and people may want to access the
dairy that are using the bus
as well i wouldn't i wouldn't think the
impact would be um huge it might mean
people have to walk a little bit further
um and that would be the main issue
thank you
further questions couple from me
questions
yes please kirsten
just how do we look i just wondered why
where was the previous bus stop that
you're now putting outside pepper tree
on the other side of the road because
obviously it was a previous through when
wooden hit a bus service
and there is you're putting an existing
one where there is still a bus stop
where was the previous bus stop on the
other side of the road
all right look to be honest kirsten i'm
not entirely sure i have a feeling it
might have been closer to the
east belt uh intersection but um
the roundabout went in um so yeah that i
i suspect it was
probably opposite um and yes so now
obviously
we don't want it in that position close
to the roundabout because it's not
safe for the um in that area so it keeps
moving
so there's no room to put it closer to
the warehouse area
like actually in the warehouse area at
all no there's all
um there's not enough road reserve there
and it's all no parking
through there yeah right and the second
question i've got i've got a big concern
with devlin avenue opposite devlin
avenue
and the space there we're already having
trouble with cars turning right there
and cars going around them even though
it's a
lower speed limit they go quite fast
because it currently looks like a
rural environment why have you put the
bus directly opposite the intersection
and not staggered it slightly either
forward
or back so there is a an existing sort
of lay-by area there at the moment that
which people use to pass
cars that are turning right so they will
look too wide in there
the school bus stops there now as well
so we will look to widen it
um there's there is trees all through
there as well so there's quite limited
space to try and secure another area
that's
long enough for a bus to pull into and
pull out of where it would probably
require the removal of some of the trees
the roadside trees which
i don't it's probably not desirable
which may have to go under the new plan
that grant talked about with the
development as well
so i'm just raising that as a concern
because
and which school bus are you talking
about because there's no longer ring
your
students coming from would end
um yeah look i i know there was some
time ago
yeah i'm i'm just off the top of my head
this was a little while back that the
bus stop would stop any of the school
bus
um so yeah i just wondered whether there
would be any room to pull it back closer
to more the
the um is it mcphail ave area because
there's a lot more population
in that area as well i just wondered
about the about
just the consideration of not putting
quite so close to that busy intersection
where we do get traffic speeding
yeah like it's again
there's not actually a lot of shoulder
room through there and uh also
just um consciously there will be a
feeder into that area as well
um it would have been nice we would even
the one on the other side it's not
that ideal it's just east of um
but again the road is very narrow we
have cycle lanes further down as well
um on road which predicts another
problem but look we will we will monitor
all these bus stops and certainly
take any feedback on board that if our
residents or
uh motorists give us um that was my
major concern
that when i'm concerned about traffic
safety in that area sure
yep no don't get on board well you've
got an assurance kirsten
they'll be monitored so that's that's
good news any other questions
i i had a question someone got a
recommendations
oh can i ask monique
my initial thoughts go for it excuse me
um my initial thought was a number of
the packs
and so a number of the bus stops are
directly opposite intersections
is that considered the safest place for
them as in
i um i just thought you'd have a bit of
a bottleneck with traffic
potentially turning and traffic coming
out from intersections
but i imagine in your um
since you've studied the subject you
know more about how bus stops are
supposed to be positioned
do you get my drift sorry i just missed
the first part of your um
your question you're talking about buses
close to intersections
yeah the bus stops seem to be correct in
front of quite a number of intersections
and i presume that is considered a safer
option for them
is that correct so it
can depend um we try not place them
where they will block visibility for
cars pulling out
um on onto an intersection but
the reason for putting them really close
to intersections is they help to serve
the catchment area
um so that's where people will access
the stock from
uh so the likes of high street so a
number of them are
fairly close to intersections but
definitely um
trying to mitigate the safety aspects
often the intersection also has
a good lighting and that is a another
key area that we look for
in providing safety for people in on and
off the buses
um trying to provide some good lighting
so
um well yeah look there is
it can be sort of uh concerned one way
it's trying to mitigate them another way
and um yeah again we will
keep an eye on all of these and if we
get feedback that there are concerns
we'll certainly address them
thank you any
any other questions jim morris here
i
i'm very interested in paul and
piersgy's comments i um
the bus stop outside the player to me is
going to do with car parks which
do have cars in them quite often and i
travel apples and foods that way
another concern the one on kippenberger
avenue
um when they subdivide or
put the houses on inches property is
going to be
there's going to be entrance way onto
kimber avenue is that gonna
in some way tie in with the bus stop now
or is it going to have to shift at all
seems an odd place to put a bus stop
outside different there
yeah look again it comes back to where
we can actually fit
a bus stop in um there's it's around 25
meters that you need for the bus at a
minimum for the bus to pull in and to be
able to pull out
um so as i say there is an area there
now um and and if things if the layout
changes certainly we will address that
um
and i can't for you know i can't
forecast that or i can't sort of plan
for that
without knowing what exactly what's
going on
um but and and just in regard to
the um the parking back by the plow
uh yeah look it's just um
it's incredibly difficult to get
residents to agree
to have a bus stop outside their
property
um for whatever reason they they do have
some thoughts about
bus users which um yeah where that comes
from i'm not sure but
um so trying to mitigate that by
utilizing areas that are going to be the
least impact on residences
is has been one of the reasons that
we've chosen some of the areas
um happy to go back and have another
look but i suspect
uh we may still have some uh walls with
as i say people objecting to a bus stop
outside their property
any any other questions
i will just observe that i think bus
stops
are one of the more difficult issues you
deal with as a community board member
over the years because as cathy said no
one says they're in the right place
unlocked and they're only in the right
place if they're well away from your
home
so it's always been a sort of difficult
situation
right we've got some recommendations in
front if someone prepared to
test the meeting or move something
someone must have an idea
well i'll test the meeting then i'll
i'll move
a and b approves the installation of the
listed am i seconded for that yes
sarah okay
thank you sarah well i don't really want
to say anything i think the questions
asked her all been
really relevant uh kathy has said that
she will monitor
the stops to make sure that the concerns
uh are indeed looked at
uh i think the one morris raised along
east belts a very valid point he
makes too so i i just moved it to move
it along
and hope that and in the knowledge that
staff will indeed
check what's happening is here you wish
to add anything
um i think there's some good ones there
yes can you hear me
yeah can you hear me or not yeah yeah no
there's some good ones on there i've had
a good read of them
and where i live which is near river
road we were we had some gaps which i
can see have been
catered for so that's good i'm happy
any other members wish to speak
yeah i'll be voting for this but i would
actually really like to start for a bit
more investigation
on the um kittenberger avenue one
um and also the one outside the player
because i would wouldn't like to see um
every time i've been past here
particularly on by the power there it's
very hard to get parking
and also down by the um
the cabin burger avenue parking is at a
premium as well
so um i just like to see a wee bit more
investigation there but um
overall i would support this
any any other contributions yes kirsten
yes um just just to to
reiterate that my questions were in no
way um
concerned about what the staff are
trying to do we have to have these bus
stops
they have to be near population centres
and it's never easy finding a space to
put them
and i totally agree with what they've
tried to do
in all these situations i'm happy that
they've agreed to monitor
but i do think that safety should be
come before a tree
so you know if it is necessary that
should be brought to the board
and if anything does happen in those
situations because
i have seen some near misses at mcphail
have with cars not being able to get
past
and kippenberg devlin eve so i'm just
wanting to make sure that that is that
we keep the finger on the pulse on those
because people still have to come first
and we the bus stops have to be put in
those locations
so kathy thank you very much for for a
good job you've tried so
hard to not cause trouble for residents
which i can see you've done a lot of
work in that space
and you're always going to get
complaints but i think what you've done
is very balanced and it's very fair and
as
sarah said it's going to actually
benefit an awful lot of residents
who've really wanted this bus service
particularly
in the uh the west of rangiora and in
woodin and pegasus so thank you very
much for the work you've done
anybody else
who someone is wanting to speak
no one wanting to speak all right i'll
put the recommendat
with someone wanting to speak no i just
made them i was just going to say
i will go back and have a look at the
certainly the plough one and see if we
can't
uh mitigate that um so yeah just wanted
to note
that um thank you kathy
that that's that's that's good all right
i'll put the recommendation
all those in favor please say hi to the
country
hi clear it carried
i yeah right moving on to 6.4
um that's for
information okay do you want to add
anything there
i'm just ready for information so yes
there's nothing else
other than um
okay someone prepared to move it moved
by sarah
segmented by monique happy with that
good i put that all those in favor
please say i
contra carried item seven correspondence
uh who
who would be who would be keen
uh or would like to be the community
board rep to the sustainability strategy
steering group
please please indicate um monique would
you like to do that that would be
probably suit you you or you'd be good
for the
represent the board there is anyone
volunteering what is it about jim
uh if you if you had
read the agenda you would have seen it
in the
in in the main book it's really just to
look at the way forward for
for the community on sustainability
okay do you want to add to that um
right i haven't really got very much to
say other than i have been told that
the sustainability steering group will
be
um being a lot of liaison with the
community
and the board and the council to
um move forward sustainable options
and also the um climate change
subcommittee will also eventually
join up with this group and it will
become the two of them will work to get
good outcomes for the council and the
community regarding sustainability and
count
and climate change
right have we got anyone that's prepared
to
yeah maybe to make it a little less
scary
is i mean it might feel like you've got
quite a responsibility like maybe how
many people would you be
on a group with if your parents
there's a council rep and one from each
community board
right it just might help someone make a
decision if they don't feel like
you know
mr chair if you're happy for us to
comment because we were given quite a
good briefing on this
um that'd be most helpful i think thank
you
this this group is is combining um the
sustainability champions that we've
already got and staff within the
organization
with the governance side of things so
there is actually two councillors
councillor mailings and councillor
blackie on this group
and then we've asked for a rep from each
of the community boards so that we get
community input as well
the first thing is getting our own house
in order so that the council makes sure
that it is
practicing sustainable practices and
then looking at how the council can
facilitate sustainability in the
community
so they're not completely responsible
for sustainability through the whole
district
but it's actually a starting point to
try and look at some practices
and we would really value the community
input on that
thank you kirsten for that that was most
helpful
i have to say so you've got a better
idea of what it's about who
who wants to um
be interested i'll do it who's that
andy i don't know i can't and
andy all right sorry andy you're not on
my screen
that is okay jim i'm fine with that
andrew wells is happy to do that so
someone prepared to move that inserting
the name of
andrew i'm happy to move that jim
sarah thank you do you wish to speak to
it yep just very quickly commenting this
group is this
is the starting point and they will
report back to the community board for
us to also give further input
so everybody is involved in
sustainability and thank you andrew for
putting your hand up for it
i'm sure you'll find it quite
enlightening
[Music]
okay all right i'll put that all those
in favor please say
aye aye contrary clear clear
carried item 8.1
i'll move the adoption of the cheers
report if we're seconded for that
yes i'll do it sarah sarah
thank you sarah all right i'll put that
all those in favor please say i
i carried
item nine is for information
uh requires a motion to receive the
the information i'll move it have a
segment for that
i'm on second thing please
as i indicated at the start we've now
got don young for
a brief brief briefing on flexton
so don over to you
there's don young there thank you jim
yes i am
thanks jim um i'll just do a share
screen if that's
all right and
the intention here is just to bring the
board
up to speed with flexton road and where
we've got to as a result
of previous resolutions by the board
and council we had generally agreed
on a shared path on the western side of
flexton road
uh subsequent to that uh we've been
undertaking detailed design and that
is highlighted uh in more detail
uh the issues we would face uh by
building
a western cycle
or shared path and the
the shot that you can see at the moment
the pictures you can see
a highlight in red the areas where we
would need to build a retaining wall
alongside of that drain in order to
retain the drain in such a way that we
could fit in
the 2.5 meter sheared path and the
yellow
is where there would still be
significant road shaping to do
and this part here is further down
towards um
kingston smith is at the bottom of the
page you can see here
so as you can see there is an extensive
length of
uh of red i.e the um
the retained section the result of that
when we've costed that up is it would
exceed our budget uh by in the order of
uh eight hundred thousand dollars or so
and uh that's as as you can understand a
pretty significant
cost we have looked at other options
uh in for staying on the west including
narrowing down the shared path and
potentially narrowing up some of the
road
alignment neither of these were
preferred we'd still retain
a very risky
location which could be scoured out
even with the additional protection and
we would have compromised
on our level of service what staff have
been working
on since then and you can see in this
slide here and i appreciate these slides
are very difficult to see so what we
will be doing
is forwarding these plans to you uh
within the next couple of days so that
you can view them
in the privacy of your own home and
effectively
what we have drawn on here is an eastern
footpath
now i'm aware that there was some
conversation earlier on
about whether we should go east and west
and as a result of that the western one
was preferred for a number of reasons
which are
been a benefit to the pedestrians and
cyclists
unfortunately with this additional
information
that those initial thoughts are
outweighed
by the the issues that we're now facing
with regard to the
stability of of the drain so effectively
what we would be like what we would like
to suggest to the board
is that we do go back and revisit
the uh the eastern drain
why this is important for the board to
reasonably urgently get a briefing on
this is that we do have a
pretty tight time frame that will be
necessary
for us to to to keep this moving and
and spend our money uh this slide i'm
showing up now again you'll find some
real difficulty
in seeing at this stage but what we
would intend to do
um and i've just met with uh your chair
and the mayor and paul williams just
prior to this
board meeting and that's when we agreed
that we would
look to squeeze a briefing in so we
could keep you informed
but what i'm looking to do is go to the
council meeting
on the 1st of september and get
approval to consult on an eastern path
we would then go back and engage with
the business
owners and come back with
um but prior to going to the business
owners we would come to your next board
meeting
and seek your uh agreement as well
now that'll be a little bit chicken and
egg and that the
council meeting will have probably met
if well will have met before your next
board meeting
so any approval they gave will be
subject to your
uh agreement as well so the two things
i'm undertaking to do is firstly
circulate to you the plans
and this powerpoint presentation which i
prepared for
discussing with jim and dan and paul
and allowing you the opportunity to come
back uh as individuals
to me as as we progress for this through
this
and then secondly also undertaking that
we'll come to your next board
for a a more formal uh resolution
um we would then be going to the to
to discuss this issue with the
businesses
uh and coming back to uh the council and
the board
at the end of that um to to to get your
agreement before going to tender
so i need to really go back through and
work out this time
frame to make sure we we have the time
to do all of that
the uh the current time frame that's
on the screen at the moment does have us
building this
uh from early january through till the
end of april and then the resurfacing
which you may recall is happening half
this year
and half in the next financial year to
fit in with our maintenance
uh budgets uh would would take place
after that
um but we do apologize for this we we
know that you know you have already made
a decision and we're back in front of
you seeking a change to that but
this is sometimes what happens when you
look more closely at these issues that
we thought
would have been able to be dealt with
through the design process but
we have sought geotechnical advice and
they have uh clearly
identified that the risk of losing our
pathway
is pretty high and that the cost of
mitigating that risk
then makes this an extremely expensive
project
so i appreciate i've given you a very
brief briefing without very much
information there but we did think it
was important that we
bring you up to speed with what we're
planning on doing and i'll circulate
more information in the next couple of
days
and i'm happy to take any questions
thank you thank you don
for that and thank you for the briefing
with dan and paul
just a couple of hours ago it became
quite
apparent during the briefing that
the cost escalation just meant that what
we were looking at previously as a board
wasn't really a starter and with the
weakness of the drain banks it was quite
quite clear that changes had to be made
and don told us at that briefing that it
may be possible to add
up to 10 parks down there on that
where if the road can be widened with in
places to allow parking along where the
drain has got stability so
that that makes sense to me too so thank
you don for that questions of don
just one from me jim
yep it's just that just
sorry refresh my memory don what were
the major objections to
going on to the eastern side
we are going to need to be uh
compromising with that shared path
alignment in a couple of ways
firstly there are power poles down the
middle
of that verge and so there will be
places where
the shared path actually splits around
those power poles
in order to provide safe
width on either side we will need to be
building out into the roadway
through those not not into the
carriageway but
where it would impact on on parking
in addition to that we were mindful that
a cycle way
uh close to the fences
uh can be uh
have some safety issues um and what
we've done there is we
in particular at the rangiora landscape
we have shifted again the cycleway out
by a margin to allow a green strip
um so there will be some degree of
separation between
the fence and the cycle way we will be
including in our design jutter bars
on the driveways as people are exiting
those
and also signage for the cyclists
to show that you know they're
approaching those issues so
it certainly elevates
some safety issues which we will need to
carefully design we've looked at that
with bill rice
a traffic engineer and we've also had a
preliminary
feedback from our road safety auditors
both of them have commented
not ideal but can be managed
so we we we certainly know we have some
issues there and i'm sure they will be
raised in uh
in no uncertain terms when we do go to
those eastern
businesses and we will need to talk
carefully with them about
how we manage those
any any other questions of dawn
all right don well thank you very much
sorry
um sporos here jim don
yep early on it was disgusting typing
the drain but there was going to cost
about a million dollars which was
um unaffordable is there
a stage into the future where that may
be done
to give you what you actually want or
what you're proposing now is that going
to be sort of final
we're always going to have that drain
there and the footpath will be on the
eastern side
i think in fairness morris it would be
probably appropriate to see it as being
final for the next
you know 15 or 20 years this this will
set
in stone i think the the layout
for the foreseeable future uh and it
would take
some you know quite significant change
to
to go to that next level of expense of
piping that drain
and i wouldn't note we
we have when we looked at putting this
cycle way on the eastern side
we have done a little bit of an analysis
of then
being able to potentially in the future
build a footpath
only 1.5 meters on the western side
now that's not part of this current plan
and that would be another 300 000
or so but i would point out that if we
took on board
the suggestion made by uh jim and dan
and paul
at the briefing that we do allow for
some parking on that western side
then that will probably eliminate the
ability to put us
footpath down that side in the future
because we
we wouldn't be able to align that curb
to allow space behind it
because we would in fact be aligning
that curve closer to the drain
to allow parking in in in the
intermediate place so
as usual there are some trade-offs there
and if the important thing is seen
as allowing for some car parking it
probably eliminates the the footpath
all of the way along the length but
sorry just one more point
we are only taking the drain out of
the 2.5 meter cycle way as far
as the
uh the transfer station and what we
would
what we have allowed in the price is for
a crossing point in the middle of the
road
and a 1.5 meter footpath
on the western side of the road
to link it all the way down to kingsford
smith drive
so the the eastern
shed path option does include
a short stretch of western footpath
just north of kingsford smith drive
don could that cycle away also link
through by the station near to the
passchendaele path
yes we've we've as you know
um kitty has some plans on buying a
strip of land alongside
uh the existing driveway now whether
that land is
is sufficient
a potential other option is that we
we look to taking a strip of land along
the frontage of germans
to link down to daniel smith's new
venture and we've discussed this briefly
with daniel at one of the other meetings
about the
roundabout and he sees he he is actually
quite keen on the idea of it being on
the east
because uh he sees that as being the
natural side that people will want to
be on if they're going on through
flexton and on down
potentially to to his
new venture but also potentially
wrapping around into fernside road
and getting out onto passchendaele uh
down that
uh short of stretch of fernside road
thank you other questions of don
all right don well thank you very much
for
keeping the board updated on the flex
scenario it's appreciated
right item 10 members information
exchange
uh i'm just kirsten
start with you
yeah yes i'm coming sorry i was just
trying to find my
email because i'd actually emailed
something through
to sorry one moment
oh telephone right um yes very quickly
i attended the covert 19 social recovery
workshop
and there'll be further follow-ups about
social recovery in our district
um i've been part of the four september
event planning obviously we don't know
what will happen now with the change of
status
but at the moment we're full stream
ahead for a
event in kaiapoi at on friday the 4th of
september at 5 pm
we encourage everybody to come along and
attended the waimakari visitor strategy
workshop which was a really interesting
look
at how we might have to reposition
ourselves with domestic tourism
and plans going forward and i've
attended the
social solid waste working party but
i'll let robbie deal on that
on quick council news uh the draft
cemetery strategy is now out for
consultation
so there'll be an uh chance for the
board to input on that
and the draft climate change policy was
approved at council
uh but the consultation on that is to be
advised so
we just needed to have a policy in place
and then
take it out to the community for some
conversations ongoing in the latest
national uh natural hazards latest
modeling
of maps has now been released and these
presentations obviously coming up on the
28th and 29th of august
in rangiora that's the 29th of august at
5pm
and during this month the board will be
emailed
access to the maps the new maps with the
new flooding projections
based on the latest modeling and if
you've got any questions come back to
staff on that
it's predominantly the biggest changes
are in kaiapoi and in some
cases it's actually for the better but
it does require us to make some
adjustments to the district plan in
terms of floor height
and modeling going forward so it they're
not as relevant for rangiero but still
of great interest
and that's me thank you kirsten
i don't think duncan's with us is he
nope
no right rob robbie
i'm taking your names off the agenda in
the order of their peers so you might
wonder
when you're coming up so robbie your
next please
just trying to unmute um so
uh yeah joined landfill committee met
this week so we've adopted the soi with
tree hands waste
um joint standing committee met after
after that then there were five projects
that received funding
for a reduction of waste touching on
what
kirsten mentioned and this is uh very
important
uh the soul from has
this waste working party
have been dealing with a very serious
issue with regard to recycling
we recycling has cost our district 122
over a three month uh period a letter is
going out
to all uh households
albeit to the addressed person so
if you're a landlord you need to pass
this letter on to your
attendance with regard to
your recycling and how you are managing
to recycle the rejection rates
are horrendous and depending on how this
covert thing
pans out we will be looking
at auditing in september we are looking
at potentially people losing the option
of a yellow bin for systematic failure
to recycle appropriately and hence those
auditors will be going out
look in a nutshell given the format that
we're in i can't go into
too much detail a letter is coming out
that's been drafted
for heaven's sake read the letter
encourage people that you know to read
the letter
and if you are a landlord encourage your
tenants to read the letter the
ramifications
of how we're currently recycling
uh is is not sustainable and
um and changes need to be made so
that's my big message for tonight jim
given the current format
thank you robbie it was raised with me
robbie that um
there was an article in the paper the
council had there about
about the issues you raise and to look
for the letters recycle
and the triangle on the bottom there are
some plastic
um things that look look all right that
have got recyclable written on the
bottom
but they're actually imports from
australia and they don't meet
our criteria as i understand it just so
you're aware of that
it was raised with me so i said i'd tell
you yeah
yeah yeah there should there'll be a
number there should be a number down
in the in the bottom of the um of the
plastic
uh container that will indicate whether
it's acceptable
a new magnet a new sticky on the sorry
kirsten's idea was a magnet we're not
doing the magnet
but there's a new sticky that's going to
be going
into the yellow bin you can put it in
which will clearly explain it um so
yeah but it's all in the letter the big
thing is
the letter good okay
that's good robbie thank you very much
monique
monique hi yes yeah hello um mine
relates to keep bringing your beautiful
hello um they keep ranking you're
beautiful
we're concerned about flex and road and
lack of trees etc and beautification
on these new road you know when they're
developing these roads that we're not as
a community board considering
the uh the beautification of the roads
and so
i said maybe they should come along to
the community board meeting and and
um educate us on
how we should um consider that when we
when we approve road designs or you know
when we sort of have our say
about them maybe we could consider
having them more attractive to the
public eye with trees etc
i know flaxseed wrote it flexible was
one they were concerned about
but obviously it's rather narrow and
very difficult to probably put anything
too beautiful
along it but that was something that
came up with them
so um another thing from that meeting
was someone suggested we perhaps rangura
might consider having murals as an
attraction
as like a tourist attraction for the
town i i understand a group
won some award for some a mural for
blake street i'm not quite sure
of the details but um maybe we can maybe
can
it can be considered as a an attraction
to have to consider
putting murals out anyway that's me
thank you well certainly monique the
murals
on eye care on that corner are fantastic
i
you know that's that's beautification on
my murals
uh you mentioned um keep rangiora
beautiful
greg miller still chair of that yes
he he only has to ask any
any groups very welcome to come to the
community board
start of our meeting and have 10 minutes
to tell us what they're doing
so you pass on an invitation to greg if
he just
contacts kay that he'd be very welcome
thank you
is jason with us
hello is jason there yep yep
nothing of note your turn jason
yeah nothing of note over the last month
okay thanks jay thanks jason morris
yes i'm here jim um mr ended a couple of
meetings with with you and monique and
paul with the
southport road um i've just enablingly
been
monitoring what people's opinions are of
taking those trees down by
the ashley bridge which he can done and
also the um
quarry it's quite interesting reading
people's views and comments on that
apart from that that's all i've got to
report him
thank you morris i'll talk to kaye if uh
have a brief in
debrief with you tomorrow morning kay if
you're there and
we need to find out where the quarry's
at so the board
has plenty of time to prepare a
submission if we're still in a position
to be able to do that
and not all locked up dan did you have a
comment
no okay sarah
were you asking me to comment jim sorry
upset no i said i i saw you
move your hand i thought you might have
wanted to make it oh no no no
no no that's right sarah
hi jim um i've had a quietish month but
um i thought i'd just mention the
everyone knows that i run a
cycling and walking group out here um
and the christchurch city council
contacted me they've got a group there
that organise
a rather large walking festival and the
breeze radio station
is one of the sponsors so they have
asked me to host
a walk out here as part of the festival
for
april 2021 so that will be an
opportunity for me to
show people from whoever could be all
over new zealand coming to
wymac so i'll make sure i'll pick a good
one for that so i'll keep you posted on
on that there'll be a lot of advertising
on the radio and some pamphlets and
things as they get that organized so
that's a bit exciting um another thing i
wanted to mention was
um you know don't forget to enjoy what
we have got to offer here
in regards to um concerts
we in ring yora i'm discovering have got
the most fantastic concerts for 25
or 35 max you can go and enjoy
something here without going too far i
went to
watch um a young guy 18 years old
benedict lim his name is
play the violin at the rangara chamber
gallery
which i've never stepped foot in my
entire life and i was actually surprised
how beautiful it was
um and the reason why is because i
looked around and it really does in all
honesty attract the silver head
um and so a lot of young people i don't
really think i saw many younger people
there
and what a shame that is so
as part of the board member of the board
i've decided you know
pass that around you know it's it's
really was fantastic
you know you've got um amazing
small local artists that come out to the
belkin hall
you know once a month or once every two
months it's 35
most fantastic concerts um
it's just down the road you get supper
and just i've not
not enjoyed one at all they've been
fantastic
so i just thought i'd mention those two
even the rsa you know
there's no reason for us not to get out
and support these fantastic
beings that they have um to suit all
sorts
um and lastly just to finish um
this is for you jim i just wanted to
acknowledge that
um and give consult condolences from
myself and i'm sure
the board will follow me and say i'm
really sorry to hear that mary's
brothers passed away
on monday we're thinking of you jim
uh mary and your family at this time so
sad news but just wanted to acknowledge
that if for those on the board that may
not have
realized that so i love to marry from me
and thank you sarah that's
yeah thank you that's appreciated
you know andy that tank
behind you looks like it leaks andy yeah
it's
uh it's the heroin district's water
scheme
oh there you are hi jim it's the hiranui
district's water scheme it's not
waimakariris
right um nothing to report
uh from me thank you
all right thank you paul yeah i just
like to say andy we
the waimakariri do drink out of that um
water scheme so
be very careful um being a great
person oh my water my water comes from
that tank
that's what feeds my house i realize
that
um and sarah being a gray head just now
i'm starting to i think i might have to
go and see some of these concerts um
a bit more because i'm probably fitting
to that um
group in a few years when um gets to my
age you might not have nothing left
there you've got a
way to go here paul i have um
yeah it's for all councillors i think
we've had a really really busy
time in the last month and i think we're
going to have a busier time
next month so i actually don't know
where to start
but probably the most important thing is
i've been to the government
um three waters um scenario
nothing's been decided yet um but they
have offered the
council a carrot um of a um
quite a big chunk of money to um
do some work around our water schemes
and sewage games around
the um waimakariri that will benefit the
whole of the
community eventually um so
it's probably going to be a good thing
if we accept it we haven't decided
we've all or not but um i think we'll be
probably um seriously looking at it
because we need to be in discussions
with the government over this
three waters um thing that promises this
money with um
no hooks but um i think a few of us are
thinking there may be a few
um books involved but um i think
um we have to take this opportunity to
um take some money and um
the i think um i can mention the
projects or a couple of the projects we
may be looking at
one of them might be this um connecting
the fernside scheme
um sewage game which um
is a very very expensive system and um
um you may not get it up without a bit
of help for the government
and the other one what might be logan
lee with the
sewage side here um and we may be able
to help out
the bit of the points roadside um
scheme so um it's looking quite
promising if um
at all goes to plane but um so the short
term is but
i don't know what the long term will be
with this government um
three waters scenario but um at the
moment that promises
there's no fish hots in it so um if we
take the money
all we have to do is sit there and
consult with them um
and um that promised us that we don't
like the idea we can pull out but um
i think ben is a wee bit nervous on that
and we all are a bit nervous on that but
um we have to take a word at the stage
anyway
so um apart from that it's just been
busy busy
i did go to the opening of the gary mere
um
scheme it's all opening and operating
staff have made a really
really good job of designing it um
the price is probably less than what
we're originally expecting
and i think after all the consultation
and then did a lot of work and
consultation there
and um i think um he's made it so that
the um
the rate cars in that area are quite
happy and
um they've got a real good water scheme
now for the
going into the future so um everything's
pretty positive here as well
so it's all looking good thank you
[Music]
thank you thank you paul and uh duncan
would be pleased you mentioned the gary
mayer
water supply because that was a great
result which the previous council
said put put in place and the mayor of
course
opened it and you and i were there and
duncan was here and that's gone down
really well with locals over there so
thank you for mentioning that uh that's
the end of members exchange
items 11 and 12
uh for members information item 13
no media no questions
no urgent general business so that is
the
end of the meeting